im märz gibt es draußen endlich wieder
richtig viel zu tun und welche
gartenarbeiten jetzt draußen wichtig
sind darum geht es in diesem video
es ist ganz erstaunlich wie in
hochbeeten immer wieder die erde absagt
weil sich die erde dann so setzt und
dann können die pflanzen auf einmal
nicht mehr über den hof betrand
rausschauen wenn man da nicht ausfüllt
und der ist jetzt ein guter zeitpunkt
wenn ihr langsam das wintergemüse
aufgegessen habe das vielleicht noch in
euren hochbieten wächst aber noch nichts
neues ein gesät oder gepflanzt habt dann
einmal daran denken dass ihr die wieder
schön auffüllt lieber auch ein bisschen
mehr als man denkt weil das auch sehr
schnell wieder abflacht also ihr seht
ihr sohn schon so einen kleinen hügel
aufgeschüttet einfach weil sehr viel
leichter ist wenn man das jetzt macht
wenn die beete einmal leer stehen als
wenn da immer noch pflanzen wachsen die
man ja aber auch nicht begraben möchte
märz ist es noch ein bisschen früh um
die kartoffeln zu pflanzen aber wenn ihr
kartoffeln pflanzen wollt dann ist es
jetzt ganz wichtig dass er die im haus
vor keimt dafür legt ihr die einfach an
einem hellen ort aus man kann die gut in
eierkartons machen weil sie dann nicht
umfallen und man sie dann auch leichter
von einem ort zum anderen transportieren
oder in den garten raus tragen kann und
das sorgt dafür dass aus den kartoffeln
kurze kleine gedrungene triebe raus
kommen also nicht diese ganz langen
weißen die man kennt wenn man die ein
bisschen zu lange im schrank liegen
lässt wir wollen die kurzen triebe die
sind meistens entweder grün oder lila
und die sorgen dafür dass die kartoffeln
wenn sie dann so ins beet gepflanzt
werden schon den ordentlichen
wachstumsvorsprung haben
wenn ihr einen tribut kasten in ihrem
garten haben denkt daran dass ihr den
jetzt regelmäßig lüften
das ist sehr cool im frühbeet kasten zu
gärtnern gerade so früh im jahr kann man
da schon sehr viel mehr anbauen als
draußen im beet aber eben daran denken
dass die pflanzen auch luft brauchen
weil wenn man vergisst ihn zu lüften
dann fangen die pflanzen ganz schnell an
zu verfaulen und das wird ziemlich
schnell ziemlich eklig deswegen mache
ich das so dass ich den kasten einfach
offen lasse und lüfte solange ich im
garten bin und wenn ich wieder gehe
mache ich ihn wieder zu so dass die
pflanzen tagsüber immer mal ein bisschen
frische luft schnuppern können
vielleicht habt ihr ein paar pflanzen in
ihrem garten als winterschutz mit
tannenzweigen abgedecktes murmelt die ja
immer ganz schön ein damit sie nicht
erfrieren
aber jetzt wird es langsam wieder wärmer
und dann treiben die pflanzen wieder aus
und dann ist es ja doof wenn die gar
nicht austreiben können weil die
tannenzweige auf ihn drauf liegen
deswegen habe ich zum beispiel ist beim
eine artischocke die tanz weil wir
beiseite getan und die nur ein bisschen
stroh eingemummelt das so leicht ist
dass sie einfach austreiben kann aber
sie trotzdem noch vor den letzten
frösten schützt die ja bestimmt noch
kommen werden es ist ja total klug wenn
man die beete den winter über mich weil
das den boden vor erosion geschützt weil
er dann vor wind und wetter geschützt
ist und nicht so schnell weggeht und
weggeschwemmte wird und auch weil das
die pflanzen vor dem forst isoliert aber
jetzt wenn es wärmer wird dann isoliert
der wohlig auch den boden vor der sonne
und deswegen kann der boden sich nicht
so gut erwerben wenn der mitarbeiter
liegt und deswegen fange ich jetzt an in
den beeten in den in den nächsten wochen
neue junge pflänzchen oder welche
aussagen einziehen sollen den muss ich
bei seite zu ziehen ich nehme dafür
immerhin rechnen und dann zusteht muss
ich einfach auf den weg weil er da nicht
im weg ist aber immer noch ganz nah bei
den pflanzen so dass wir dann wenn es
wieder wärmer geworden ist im mai den
muss ich auch wieder zwischen den
pflanzen verteilen können
dann gibt es noch eine aufgabe bei den
erdbeerpflanzen es kann sein dass ihr
das schon im herbst gemacht habt so wie
ich falls nicht jetzt mal gut aufpassen
und zwar ist es ganz wichtig bevor die
jetzt wieder richtig austreiben dass man
einmal durch geht und die ganzen alten
blätter entfernt weil die oft
pilzkrankheiten haben die sich dann
wieder auf die neuen pflanzen übertragen
oder auf die neu ausgeschriebenen
blätter übertragen könnten deswegen
jetzt einmal schönes erdbeben aufräumen
damit die pflanzen auf schön gesund
bleiben wenn ihr meinen kanal schon
länger verfolgt dann habt ihr bestimmt
schon gesehen dass ich manche gemüse
wenn man mit so komischen tüchern
abdecke das sind insektenschutz netze
oder kultur schutznetze die sollen dafür
sorgen dass wir die gemüse die besonders
schnell von schädling aufgefuttert
werden beschützen damit wie sie selber
essen können und ich packte vor allem
auf alle cool gewächse also kohlrabi
weißkohl rotkohl wirsing grünkohl und so
weiter und auch auf den lauf bei der von
der laut fliege befallen wird und die
kohlgemüse haben auch eine ganze armada
von schädlingen und so kann man die sehr
einfach schützen ohne dass man
irgendwelche gifte drauf springen muss
die kutsche schutznetze beschwerlich
immer mit steinen damit der wind nicht
drunter greifen kann die nicht
wegfliegen und auch damit die schädlinge
nicht runter kommen und was ganz
praktisch ist wenn man sich bögen aus
elektroinstallation skoren baut die
chips im baumarkt ich nehme immer die
aus der baath abteilung mit dem
aluminium kern weil die viel beständiger
sind und auch weil die im winter nicht
einfach kaputt frieren das ist bei den
reinen plastikrohren leider manchmal der
fall und darauf baue ich mir dann mögen
die stecke ich in die erde und so kann
man sich kleine tunnel aufbauen so dass
das netz die gemüse auch nicht so
unterdrückt
und diejenigen von euch den rhabarber
pflanze im garten haben können jetzt mit
einem trick dafür sorgen dass sie viel
früher ernten können und zwar schnappt
ihr euch da jetzt einfach mal einen
eimer und stirbt denn jetzt über die
rabatt lanze drüber so dass die schönen
dunkeln hockt weil dann treibt ihn
nämlich viel früher aus und wie können
früher im jahr ernten märz kann man ja
schon einige gemüsepflanzen nach draußen
pflanzen welche das sind dazu später
noch mehr aber wichtig ist dass wenn ihr
die pflänzchen dann nach draußen setzt
das ihr dann auch an den schnecken
schutz denkt weil die schnecken werden
jetzt auch wieder viel aktiver wenn es
wärmer wird und die kleinen jungen
pflänzchen sind natürlich sehr sehr
empfindlich weil sie sind so zart und
lecker dass die rückzug aufgetreten sind
und deswegen das pflanze ich meine
jungpflanzen immer in so einen schnecken
kragen das ist ein ring gibt es aus
plastik oder auch aus metall die sind
dann halt ein bisschen stabiler aber
auch richtig gut das ist dann so sie in
dem löwenkäfig dass der zaun muss so ein
bisschen überrannt und deswegen können
die da nicht rein und damit sind eure
jung zu entziehen geschützt kann euch
beide auf jeden fall mal energie die
beschreibung verlinken wenn ihr gucken
was ich da benutzte eine ganz wichtige
aufgabe im märz ist natürlich die
aussaat im beet oder auch die antwort im
haus und wenn ihr wissen wollt welche
gemüse jetzt aussehen könnt dann schaut
man da trieben vorbei ansonsten geht
raus und macht die welt ein bisschen
grüner er habe einiges zu tun im garten
und wir sehen uns nächsten samstag um 10
für ein neues video zu